what's going on guys this is Robin this
just let you guys know that I'm actually
going to be leaving town on a wednesday
i'm going to be taking off for i guess
the rest of the week I'm going into like
monday or tuesday so i actually won't
have any uploads past tuesday i thought
i'd be able to have Age of Apocalypse
for the most part finished by then but i
forgot how like huge this story is so
we'll pick back up with age of
apocalypse on monday or tuesday and then
we'll give you guys a chance to sort of
go to the video and try to make sense of
stuff well also have down in the in the
description of the video is a link to
the reading order for age of apocalypse
for those of you guys who are interested
in the story who want to get the story
through moment unlimited or any other
way that you can think of i'd say go
ahead and you know go that route and
check it out and that way you guys can
get a good sense of where we stand with
everything so um so yeah like I'm really
excited about Age of Apocalypse cuz
everything's so different like
everything is so totally different i
mean it's it's like there's no like
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants and there's
none of that stuff instead there's just
like everybody trying to survive but
anyway I'm just want to give you guys
heads up i don't like taking off without
giving you guys an idea of what's going
on so yeah i will i'll have the top five
Deadpool moments tomorrow and then I
will see you guys next week peace